- Ce n'est pas par honte, mais
plutôt pour des considérations
professionnelles qu'elle a
demandé de raconter anonymttt
ce qu'elle a vécu quand
elle avait 17 ans.
- Tu es avec un partenaire,
qu'il y a un certain abus, que
c'est physiqpspspsychologique
ou émotionnel, quand tu le sais
qu'à long terme, c'est pas pour
toi, que tu es pas dans une
bonne situation, tu rêves pas
d'élever un enfant là-dedans.
- Après avoir appris qu'elle
était inininte, une solution
s'est donc imposée :
l'avortement.
- L'obstacle que, moi, j'ai eu,
c'était d'avoir accès,stststste,
qui était pas disponible
dans ma région. Puis, j'ai dû
aller faire deux heures de route
pour me rendre à Bathurst.
Puis ça, c'était deux heures
aller, deux heures de retour,
puis à deux reprises.
- 11 ans plus tard
le gouvernement du Nouveau-
Brunswick ne finance toujours
que les avortements pratiqués
dans trois hôpitaux :
celui de Bathurst et les deux
qui se trouvent à Moncton.
- C'est dommage.
rarararais pouvoir avoir
ce service-là qui est offert
plus proche de ta région.
JULIE GILLET, DG, Regroupement
féministe du Nouveau-Brunswick
- On est désolées, mais c'es
pas un droit qui est accessible,
c'est pas un service accessible
quand ça nous coûte de l'argent,
quand ça nous coûte du temps.
- Cette militante pro-choix
dénonce d'ailleurs q q q q que
la province reste la seule à
ne pas financer les avortements
qui sont pratiqués en dehors
du cadre hospitalier.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier miu u u u u Canada
- Notre gouvernement va jamais
reculer dans la défense
des droits des femmes.
- Une frustration partagée
par le gouvernudududududeau,
selon qui ce refus du Nouveau-
Brunswick va à l'encontre de ses
obligations en matière de santé.
- On est en train de financer
des études pour regarder
la réalité de l'accès,
qu'on sait, n'est pas pareil
partout au pays. Et donc,
nous sommes en train de regarder
exactement ce qu'on peut et doit
faire de plus pour assurer que
toutes les femmes ont ce libre
choix à travers le pays.
Pour ces députés de
l'opposition, les libéraux
ont du rattrapag
en la matière.
ALAIN RAYES, député, PCC,
Richmond - Arthabaska, Qc
- Si vous faites le recensement
de tout tététététété fait
depuis sept ans pour améliorer
l'accessibilité puis la sécurité
aux femmes qui souhaitent
se prévaloir de ce choix-là,llle
chose de complètement nul.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chef, Bloc québécois
- Donc, un cadre à l'endroit
de juridictions qui
sont plus restrictives,
je le comprendrais, mais
il faut pas que ça vienne
s'ingérer dans ce que sont
les compétences des provincesou.
- Mais pour celles qui
l'ont vécu, ce n'est pas
une question politique...
- Le fait d'avoir des choix
quant à son corps,
des décisions qui sont prises,
c'est un service qui devrait
être partout.
- ... Mais plutôt
une question de dignité.
Ici Mathieu Papillo